vor acht Jahren gab es so ein richtig
komischen Trend auf Youtube dass man
seinen Zuschauern die Apps vorgestellt
hat die man damals halt auf seinem Handy
so hatte und ich dachte mir Mensch es
ist zwar nicht mehr 2014 aber wir können
den Trend ja mal wieder aufleben lassen
und vielleicht hatte ich auch einfach
keine Video Idee für heute Politik
Content hallöchen meine lieben Freunde
und
es ist so Grinch ne wieso habe ich das
Video überhaupt mit 16 % aufgenommen ich
hoffe wirklich es klappt von der
Qualität dass ihr es erkennen könnt weil
guck mal wenn ich näher Range ich habe
aber nicht so ein gutes Objektiv es ist
einfach alles low budget auf meinem
Kanal genauso wie jetzt hier auch ich
werde euch auch heute wieder so ein paar
Apps zeigen die ich auf meinem Handy
habe und so ein bisschen so ein
Vergleich machen zu damals also fangen
wir jetzt mal hoffentlich an mit der
ersten App hier und ich habe halt ein
iPhone 5 oh mein Gott das erste oder 5c
ey das sieht mega cool aus so ja ultra
cool ey also ich habe hier ein iPhone
13 oder sowas iPhone 14 sorry sehe ich
absolut gar nicht gut arbeiten
so Standard App halt Nachrichten die ist
das immer noch genauso seht ihr hier
oben
der Fokus klappt noch nicht weil ich ne
ach guck mal er hat's Nachrichten habe
ich immer noch hier ganz oben will ich
jetzt nicht draufklicken aber ganz
normale Nachrichten halt also hier haben
wir dann Eis studies das ist eine sehr
sehr coole App da steht du hast heute
frei hier kann der Kalender so mit
meinem Schulplan dies das da steht oh
mein Gott stimmt da war ich ja noch in
der Uni also hier habe ich aktuell
meinen normalen Kalender ne und man hier
die Camps wieder zu switchen ganz
normaler Kalender den ich mittlerweile
nutze Fotos ganz klar halt einfach Fotos
ja habe ich immer noch so also ihr seht
ja hier Fotos habe ich immer noch genau
gleich angeordnet daneben Kamera App um
halt einfach ja die Fotos Halt zu machen
Kamera um Fotos zu machen
[Musik]
aber einfach alles genau gleich gut
Anordnung ich sag genau das gleiche
Digger was ist das für ein Opfer der das
da gemacht hat dann haben wir hier
Youtube oh mein Gott wie das aussieht
ist natürlich ein Muss für ein Youtuber
empfohlenen Videos okay aber es ist so
lachig ich habe immer noch Youtube hier
genau in der gleichen Stelle nur das
nächste habe ich dann Amazon App weil
das hat sich bei mir über den letzten
Jahren entwickelt dass ich übel viel
einfach bei Amazon mache dann haben wir
hier Notizen wo ich halt ein paar Sachen
eintrage wie
ach keine Ahnung so warte ich mir noch
kaufen muss irgendwie da schreibe ich
dann so rein so ja Rasierklingen Shampoo
die Stars oder mittlerweile mache ich
alles über Notizen Notizen Kalender und
Erinnerungen App könnte ich nicht mehr
ohne leben also hier
Notizen sind mittlerweile hier und
Erinnerungen hier die App gab es halt
damals noch nicht sieht man auch gar
nicht mal so gut ne mit der Kamera immer
noch nobodyched aber wir waren ohne die
beiden Apps kann ich echt nicht mehr
leben dann haben wir hier die meist
genutzte App von mir WhatsApp ja einfach
zum Schreiben seht ihr auch hier
Facebook Messenger ich habe auch hier
noch eine Facebook App habe ich nicht
mit diesem Messenger einfach an sich die
Push Benachrichtigungen kommen schnell
an man kann besser Videos und Filme
versenden ach Videos und Filme Videos
und Bilder versenden und sowas alles
Facebook Messenger finde ich einfach
cooler ja ähm
dict.cc ja das war halt der Übersetzer
den ich damals immer genutzt habe habe
ich jetzt halt nicht mehr damals brauche
ich das halt wirklich für Schule und
sonnenkrams und wenn man Hausaufgaben
gemacht hat das ging einfach am
schnellsten aber mittlerweile habe ich
halt nicht mehr hier drauf dann kommen
wir hier in meinen Ordner brudis
wenn man den App Store wo man sich halt
Apps downloaden kann ist oder PlayStore
und anderen weil bevor der sich jetzt
noch weiter zum Affen macht warum also
warum denn brudis
okay aber wenn man auf jeden Fall App
Store App drin und mal ganz kurz zu
switchen die habe
ich normalerweise mal hier
aber ich glaube die habe ich jetzt im
Apple Ordner hier genau da habe ich
meine Apple dann aber hier Sport1 da
nutze ich mittlerweile Kicker habe ich
hier vorne drauf ne dann hat er hier
damals äh Gmail noch in dem Ordner drin
gehabt ich nutze nur noch Mail also die
normale Apple App dafür Skype nutze ich
gar nicht mehr sondern nur noch FaceTime
also das Apple Skype quasi Shazam nutze
ich auch nicht mehr da nutze ich einfach
auch Siri also von Apple quasi das ist
einfach sagen dass ey wie heißt das Lied
so nach dem Motto und er keine Ahnung
was das ist das ist wirklich irgendwas
mit aufnehmen damals Amazon hatte ich in
dem Ordner drin das habe ich gesagt
jetzt hier
echt viele bei Amazon bestellen und
Aktien oder habe ich ja damals die
Aktien App aber mittlerweile habe ich
halt trade Republic und er ist so eine
richtig richtig coole App ich zeige euch
noch ein paar von in die richtig cool
wäre keine Internetverbindung aber finde
ich richtig cool gestaltet so was halt
gerade so im Fernsehen läuft oh mein
Gott
ich dachte und er wäre eine App gewesen
um irgendwie 100 Teilen aufzunehmen für
Videos aber ich hatte die wirklich um zu
gucken was gerade aktuell im Fernsehen
läuft
bro
ich habe einfach mittlerweile seit vier
fünf Jahren kein Fernseher Anschluss
mehr ich schaue kein Fernsehen mehr das
ist es ist unfassbar wie ich mich auch
als Mensch verändert habe oder wo ich
mich auch nicht verändert habe Dortmund
war ich letztens und da war es halt so
ich wir wollten halt irgendwo essen
gehen ich einfach wohin angemacht und
dann kann man da halt auswählen
nein kann man hier halt Essen auswählen
und dann ich habe jetzt kein
Internetverbindung aber kannst halt
alles auswählen auch sofort holen und
alles mögliche Alter
es ist schon irre wie mittlerweile alles
hierüber gemacht wird ne alles läuft ja
mittlerweile über Karten wenn du
irgendwo unterwegs bist und du willst
irgendwie Restaurant suchen oder kannst
du auch Siri Fragen oder keine Ahnung
was also es ist verrückt zu sehen wie
viele Apps von damals ist einfach nicht
mehr gibt weil Apple die einfach kopiert
hat und standardmäßig als Apple Apps mit
aufs iPhone gepackt hat und welche Games
flappy bird oh mein Gott flappy bird gab
es damals noch
ey ey das ist so Nostalgie aber gut wir
können auch ja mal ganz kurz durch den
Candy crush kennt glaube ich jeder
kickstar Gott ist halt mittlerweile
kickbase hier habe ich immer noch drauf
das ist sondern Manager App die man mit
Freunden hat bin halt großer Fußballfan
von daher habe ich das hier ridiculous
jetpack Joyride Doodle Jump und die
magische Miesmuschel sind auch noch Apps
die teilweise noch habe ich hier Switche
mag eben kurz hier wieder drauf dann
sieht man hier kurz meine Spiele äh klar
Clash Royale bin ich riesengroßer Fan
von ich kann es euch mal ganz kurz dir
zeigen wie ich da gerade auf perfekt ich
habe kein Internet weiter geht sie mit
meinem Spiele Ordner das sind die Spiele
die ich aktuell hier habe auf meinem
Handy fotolett sehr sehr geil wenn man
mit Freunden unterwegs ist da kann man
nämlich dann sagen okay jeder packt
seine Bilder in die App rein und dann
zeigt einem die App ein Bild an und dann
muss man mit seinen vier fünf Kollegen
Erraten von wem dieses Bild ist also wer
dieses Bild auf seinem Handy hat chicken
Royal muss man mit einem Hühnchen meine
Straße laufen brain out habe ich noch
von Youtube Videos Brawl Stars kennt
glaube ich jeder im Monga kennt jeder
Doodle Jump kennt jeder Dummkopf das ist
Durak das stabil mir mal mit Sandra und
so so ein Kartenspiel aber auf dem Handy
die Bombe ist so ein Trinkspiel die
magische Miesmuschel habe ich immer noch
auf dem Handy braintest auch für Youtube
Videos streamgo Hero muss man schreien
ins Mikrofon damit sich die Person
bewegt Mario Kart gehen jeder und
brandfeind ist auch für Youtube Videos
wäre dann die nächste App und zwar
es Wikipedia eine App halt einfach so
ein Wikipedia für iPhone quasi so kann
man das nennen ne braucht man auch nicht
mehr
also ich bin wirklich Mensch ich mache
alles über Siri
egal ob es jetzt ein Wecker stellen ist
mich an irgendwas erinnern lassen oder
wenn ich eine Frage habe zum Beispiel
wie viele einwohner hat Lissabon wie
wird das Wetter morgen kannst du mir
kernspalten erklären weiter habe ich
dann hier Einstellungen habe ich auch
hier immer noch also viele Apps sind
wirklich am gleichen Ort geblieben
genauso wie snapchat hier rechts am Rand
war immer auf snapchat hier immer bei
mir rechts am Rand so ein paar Sachen
verändern sich einfach irgendwie nicht
sonst habe ich halt hier auf meinem
aktuellen Handy einfach nur noch hier
eine Zeile tiktok gab es halt damals
noch nicht hier drunter habe ich noch
Dateien also iCloud gab es damals auch
noch nicht und hier drunter so eine
Blitzer App Kick besser ich habe vorhin
schon gesagt Sonos das ist für meine
Musikanlage hier zu Hause mit die
Steuern kann dann die Auto App damit ich
mein Auto Orten kann sehe wenn irgendwas
passiert Ölstand etc socialblade und
Youtube Studio sind für den Youtuber
halt einfach gute Apps wegen Statistiken
etc Wetter einfach wegen dem Wetter
logischerweise und unten die App sind
bei mir Telefon dann soziales Netzwerk
Instagram Safari also ins Internet zu
gehen und Spotify und das war
tatsächlich damals vor 8 Jahren auch
schon exakt genauso
das hier sind die vier wichtigsten Apps
also bei iPhone das ist so die bleiben
halt immer da wie ich das auch so
erkläre
so machen
oh mein Gott
guck mal wie das jetzt aussieht
das hat sich ja so krass verändert ich
meine nicht ich zeige euch jetzt noch
mal wie es damals aussah
wenn man dieses diesen Screen da
hochgezogen hat und jetzt wie es jetzt
aussieht
hey es ist so irre das ist acht Jahre
her Facebook erklärt sich von selbst
opera ist einfach warum ich Safari nicht
benutze das Opera opera ist nämlich
finde ich viel cooler als safari ist
auch schneller und Spotify einfach zu
Musik hören und ich habe zurzeit keinen
einzigen kein eigenen Spotify Account
sondern ein mit einem Kumpel ja ich habe
mir das damals immer geteilt mit einem
Kollegen auf richtig broke angelehnt
mittlerweile sind wir etwas Spotify
Partner Digger mit unserem Podcast wer
hätte das denn gedacht vor acht Jahren
es ist Wahnsinn aber ja wie gesagt sind
wir hier wieder einen aktuellen Ansicht
ich habe es immer noch genau gleich
Telefon anstatt Facebook habe ich halt
Instagram anstatt habe ich mittlerweile
Safari Oper ist immer noch ein geiler
Browser allerdings habe ich halt auch
ein MacBook und habe da halt auch Safari
drauf dann ist alles halt über die Cloud
und so allerdings ist an der Stelle
dieses Video hier tatsächlich auch
vorbei ich bin jetzt nicht auf die Apps
in den Ordnern eingegangen weil er mir
hier damals wegen ein bisschen zu viel
gequatscht hat wie gesagt wenn ihr euch
das Video von vor 8 Jahren damals noch
mal komplett ausführlich anschauen wollt
dann sucht es einfach ihr werdet schon
finden und dann könnt ihr euch noch mal
ganz genau anhören was ich zu welcher
App sozusagen hatte allerdings zeige ich
euch jetzt noch mal kurz die restlichen
Apps die ich hier noch auf meinem iPhone
drauf hatte die Sache ist ich habe keine
App ausgeblendet das kann man ja machen
beim iPhone ich weiß allerdings nicht
warum weil ich habe keine Geheimnisse
ich starte einfach mal mit dem
Fotoordner da habe ich afterleitung
Bilder zu arbeiten Visco auch aber schon
lange nicht mehr benutze ich gerade
Sticker Maker um dumme WhatsApp Sticker
zu erstellen instas re66 die ist
deswegen sondern lustigen Kamera mit der
Sache und ich manchmal tiktoks gemacht
haben und Cam hi sind so ein paar
Überwachungskameras die ich überall
möglich installiert habe also egal ob
das an der Garage ist oder auch hier in
der Wohnung so eine zusätzliche App zu
meinem Sicherheitssystem dann im
nächsten Ordner travel habe ich mein
Wallet mit den ganzen Flugtickets drin
Airbnb für Wohnungen uber für
Taxifahrten freenet für Taxifahrten
Google Maps einfach wenn mal Karten
irgendwie nicht funktionieren sollte
über eats zum Essen bestellen Immoscout
hinsichtlich weil es einfach interessant
finde mit Immobilien mal so ein bisschen
zu gucken in verschiedenen Städten
Corona war nicht natürlich jederzeit auf
dem Handy DB Navigator für die Deutsche
Bahn booking um Hotel zu buchen
flightradar weiß ich witzig finde ab und
zu zweit wenn man so ein Himmel guckt oh
wo fliegt er den Hintern einfach so
nachzuschauen moja ist so eine auch sehr
in Hamburg habe ich aber schon ganz
lange nicht mehr benutzt Ryanair jeder
kann Ryanair jeder kennt lime die
E-Scooter google übersetzer was ich
damals die dick.cc hatte hatte ich jetzt
einfach den Google Übersetzer deliveroo
auch unten habe ich auch schon lange
nicht mehr benutzt um Essen zu bestellen
um sparen zu lernen Kopf passt wegen
meiner Impfungen Cowboy einfach wegen
meinem Elektrofahrrad urban Sports wegen
äh Sport dann habe ich hier noch was ist
das ist Made das ist um tatsächlich in
Köln kannst du Arzneimittel und zur
Apotheken Sachen wie Nasenspray oder
Augentropfen kannst du damit darüber
bestellen Eurowings einfach wegen
fliegen und egrid wegen einem E-Scooter
den ich besitze einen eigenen ähm dann
gehen wir rüber in die Apple App muss
ich euch glaube ich nicht zeigen das
sind einfach die ganzen Apple Apps die
ich hier rein verschoben habe wie gesagt
ich war bisher immer zu faul irgendwie
Apps auszublenden aber die nutze ich
halt eigentlich alle nicht ähm dann
haben wir hier vorne sonstiges schiebe
ich einfach alles mögliche rein was ich
nicht so immer benutze aber wenn ich
suche und dann weiß ich es ist da drin
Google Drive einfach ich nutze wie
gesagt iCloud aber wenn irgendwie mir
jemand Drive und dann kam ich hier drauf
dick funktioniert habe ich sogar
tatsächlich immer noch drauf von damals
PayPal um Geld zu senden Adobe Scan und
Dok zu scannen McDonald's einfach wenn
man mal da ist dann kann man auf jeden
Fall auch ein paar Gutscheine
zurückgreifen Speedtest um nutzt man
eigentlich auch nicht mehr aber einem
einfach mal zu schauen wieso die
Verbindung ist vom Internet Stock x
wegen shoppen fashion Kleidung etc n-tv
Nachrichten die ich mir per Push aufs
Handy bekomme wollte um Essen zu
bestellen hier nach Großstadt
flaschenposten Getränke zu bestellen in
der Großstadt Wetter online einfach eine
Alternativ App zum Wetter-App von iPhone
und zwar noch mit Regenradar etc drin
Lieferando natürlich auch im Essen zu
bestellen Gorillas und Lebensmittel zu
bestellen Asos Klamotten flink auch
lebensmittelfare Switch Klamotten Tipico
nutze ich eigentlich nicht mehr aber es
trotzdem mal ganz interessant mal so auf
Joke einfach für 1 € irgendwie so ein
Scheiß Mann zu gucken boah kann ich
jetzt aus dem Euro 17 Millionen gewinnen
ich habe noch nie gewonnen deswegen kann
ich euch das nicht ans Herz legen google
weiß ich gar nicht mehr warum ich die
App drauf habe also ich muss auf jeden
Fall nachher wenn man ein bisschen
aussortieren Asana ist so ein Board was
soll ich mit den Leuten vom luca-shop
habe der kam auch schon seit anderthalb
Jahren nichts mehr Merch aber es kommt
bald wieder vielleicht was von daher
planen wir dort einfach so ein paar neue
Produkte dann habe ich hier auf jeden
Fall noch den sozialordner den Ordner
lassen einfach nur so ein paar sozialer
Apps drin Sky Go Netflix mein Magenta
vom Telefonvertrag Gmail auch noch Mails
Twitch wegen Livestreams Prime Video um
Sachen zu streamen Twitter bin ich
gespannt wie es wird wenn ihnen Masters
jetzt bald übernommen hat Soundcloud da
ich auch Soundcloud immer noch viel
Musik höre und Mixes höre RTL plus habe
ich tatsächlich nur wegen der Konferenz
liegt weil Köln ja aktuell in der
Konferenz die gespielt oder wenn ihr das
Video seht vielleicht auch nicht mehr
keine Ahnung discord einfach ne kennen
glaube ich jeder der gerne zockt der
Sohn wegen Fußball gucken und Basketball
und UFC und alle Saison einfach eine
geile App und man muss ja mittlerweile
auch 1000 Streaming Anbieter auf dem
Handy haben wenn man alle möglichen
Sport Ereignisse sehen will weil die
sich die recht also aufteilen Tier wegen
E-Scooter weiß nicht warum das da drin
ist und nicht bei travel bin ich ganz
ehrlich Amazon music Shazam habe ich
immer noch auf dem Handy sogar ebay war
ich schon lange nicht mehr drin Disney
Plus und reddit dann haben wir als
letzten Ordner Games den habe ich euch
ja vorhin schon vorgestellt die Spiele
die ich aktuell auf dem Handy habe und
die allerletzte App die ich euch noch
nicht gezeigt habe ist die real Clash
Roller schon drüber gequatscht weiter
geht's hier nicht da kommen nur noch
irgendwie Sonne auch immer das hier ist
so eine Auflistung
die real einfach ja
habe ich letztens ein komplettes Video
schon mal gemacht könnt ihr mich auch
immer noch ähnliches der Laser Luca 1
aber meine Freundschaftsanfragen sind
voll deswegen kann man mich auch
vielleicht habe ich nicht mehr melden
das war's ich habe jetzt länger
gequatscht als ich eigentlich wollte und
das Video ist auch deutlich länger
geworden als ich es eigentlich vermutet
habe allerdings sind das die Apps die
ich aktuell so auf meinem iPhone besitze
was habt ihr für ein Handy schreibt's
mir mal gern unten in die Kommentare
würde mich auf jeden Fall absolut gar
nicht interessieren